willing to do whatever it takes to win
this game tonight the wizards need to
know that and pose their will
early batons for three they need that to
happen that means he's six for his last
seven
abdia surveying here's bratan's catch
and shoot for three
davis bertons two for two from downtown
if you can get this guy running towards
the basket with some momentum
he gets his feet set it's a great chance
of that ball going in
wizards can cut the lead to single
digits here comes westbrook
bertons he's three for three
defense and defense here's
bertons davis bertons four for four from
three-point land
that's what this team has been missing
davis is capable of
doing i mean this gives you the luxury
to make mistakes
on the defensive end this gives you the
luxury of turning the ball over because
he could make it up
bertons a deep three and thomas bertons
is perfect
five for five it's not over here's
bertons
for three his first of the second half
and he's six for
six that's a season high and threes for
bourtons
[Music]
bertons for three there's his seventh
westbrook doesn't get the roll
tips batons for three big
shots all because of the hustle from
russell westbrook
you know this is not over because he
comes down he misses the layup but he
sticks with it
comes back in and gets another rebound
taps it to the dove isn't it what does
he get
bertons catch and shoot for three not
this time but lopez with the offensive
rebound make them pay
batons for three they do make them pay
downtown and he has fueled this comeback
as the wizards lead by 10
here in the fourth quarter